today i would like to talk about
electrical conductivity so we're going
to try and measure the electrical
conductivity of this little aluminium
ring
so to measure the electrical
conductivity
we've got
a really big electrical conductivity
measuring device which sees how far we
can fling it
so this is a big metal coil which could
draw 100 amps if we if we could let it
and so what we do
is we switch this on
it will produce a massive current going
around it as the current builds up this
will produce a magnetic field and this
magnetic field will send currents going
around
this disk the currents going around this
disk will make another magnetic field
which will oppose the two of them and
then just like when you stick two bar
magnets together they'll fling apart
and so this should go shooting down the
lab and we'll see how far it shoots and
that will tell us how well it's
conducting so i'm just plugging in and
checking that i've not done anything
wrong good
so
so when we flick the switch it will go
bang
bang
it's gone
here we go
right so it went as far as the gloves
right so next we're going to see if we
can make this fly further try and get it
much more conducting so we get a bigger
current i have to replace the fuse each
time
because this wants to draw 100 amps
these fuses blow at 13 amps and we use
the fuses to stop the whole thing
setting on fire
okay there we go
not the fastest reloading cannon of
course not the most powerful one either
so
so the plan now is to try and increase
the conductivity so if you cool
something down it will get more
conducting so here we've got a jira of
liquid nitrogen so we dip that down into
here it's
boiling away i don't know if you can see
it boiling away right this should go a
bit further so this is on
this is ready that's steaming and boom
and
right
so down the lab don't run in a lab
we've managed to hit the back of the
wall
that's cold
so it went the whole way to the back of
the lab first time we shot it it went
from the cannon one desk two desk to the
glove we've gone one two three four five
and a bit
whole way into the wall
so that's moved over twice as far
so the piece of metal is made of lots of
different atoms so the atoms are
arranged in a lattice which is nice and
periodic but when it's at room
temperature which is quite hot
it's moving around all the time there's
lots of vibrations going through so it's
shaking around all over the place the
two are vibrating towards each other
and
when it's nice and cool this is
vibrating much less
so the current that we're trying to put
through it is made of lots of electrons
and electrons can move through the
lattice if it's nice and periodic
because of quantum mechanics their waves
they like to move through things which
are nicely arranged but if you've got
the atoms vibrating and moving towards
each other it's suddenly not periodic
anymore it comes across the sound wave
the atoms vibrating will come in and
they'll knock it off
so what you really want when you turn
when you get a current going is an
electric field which pulls all the atoms
going this way really quickly but if
you've got the temperature everything's
sloshing around electrons will be
battered off and you won't get the same
kind of
buildup of current so the first time we
did it this was jostling around a lot so
the electrons tried to get through they
were being scattered off and so the
actual current going through it was not
very much and so only went a little way
we cool it down with the liquid nitrogen
it gets nice and cold it's only moving a
tiny bit
it's only moving a tiny bit so as the
electrons try and go through less of
them are scattered
because there's less vibrations in the
crystal if less of them are scattered
more electrons shoot through the more
electron shooting through the further it
flies